i'm marie hicks i'm a historian of
technology
there used to be more women in computing
than men
where did they all go
[Music]
in the 1950s and 1960s computer
programming was decidedly women's work
but as the 1960s stretched on women
started to be replaced by men and not
just by men but management level
technocrats
the gender of the field flipped because
women were pushed out not because they
didn't have the tech skills and many
women found themselves in the position
of training their male replacements
not all of the women who were pushed out
of the workforce stopped working
computing however
dame stephanie shirley who back then
went by the moniker steve actually
started her own freelance software
company
and shirley had an explicitly feminist
business model
at this point in time most programming
was done with pencil and paper before
being run through a machine so stephanie
shirley's workers could work from home
and they could have flexible hours that
allow them to take care of children and
families
one of these workers ann moffitt
programmed the black box flight recorder
for the concord
and you can see her programming at her
kitchen table while her young daughter
looks
on but many other women just left the
field entirely
this produced an enormous skill shortage
and a huge labor shortage meaning that
the people available to do the important
work of computerization were suddenly
too few in number
as a result of this the british
government decided that they needed to
change the design of the computers that
they were using since there weren't
enough people to run them they would
concentrate and centralize computers
in conjunction with the ministry of
technology the british government forced
a merger of all of the remaining
successful computing companies and this
created one big company that was
supposed to provide the government and
the entire nation with the kind of huge
centralized mainframes that could be run
by the small number of technocrats who
are now remaining
the problem with this however is that by
the time the machine was delivered the
mainframe was on the way out and even
though icl's line of computers was
highly technically advanced it wasn't
something anyone wanted to buy anymore
this effectively destroyed the british
computing industry
and today we see similar things going on
discrimination continues to wreck
high-tech economies and high-tech labor
markets and the results reverberate out
into the rest of society
right now we see in the united states
silicon valley having a day of reckoning
in terms of how they hire promote and
decide to design their technologies all
of the talent that is lost hurts the
industry and hurts the economy but
what's more important is that
these people lack a voice in designing
critical infrastructure that we're all
going to have to live with it can
undermine the principles of democracy
by looking at examples from the past we
can find out not just how to build
better technologies but how to construct
fairer societies
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video